anie samson luc ferrandez bonsoir
bonsoir du mouvement aujourd'hui c'est
le cas des mouvements montréal
alors balarama onesse et les gens voient
cette affiche un peu partout en ville il
y en a quand même mis de l'argent il est
je vous montre pour conseiller un peu
les conséquences de ce mouvement je vous
montre un sondage léger plus tôt début
le top tout ça bouge il est à 8% holness
avec mouvement montréal et marc-antoine
desjardins à 5 pour sa ralliement pour
montréal si on les additionne ça fait
treize alors mais damas pour scène comme
ça mais ça donne un peu un ordre de
grandeur qu'est ce que vous en avez
passé annie bain premièrement je salue
la grande maturité de marquer à
marc-antoine desjardins d'avoir eu cet
esprit là avec balles à ramon holness de
10 rb si on veut vraiment se présenter
pour montréal si on veut faire la
différence ben c'est sûr que deux partis
différents d'encrés peau et le se sont
dit mais ensemble on a peut-être plus de
chance de faire rêver encore plus de
candidats de se faire connaître et se
quitter un parti moi je les ai vus lus
dans mon parti c'est déjà arrivé dans le
passé c'est pas évident pour deux chefs
surtout marc antoine qui est chef de son
parti de dire à sa gang bang août et je
pense que notre bateau va bien mais il
peut aller plus vite avec le bateau du
voisin d'à côté puis là ils sont
vraiment en train de
eh bien on est enfin oui y avancent
tranquillement et auquel chaloupe qui
s'en va avec un bateau moteur ça va
aller un peu plus vite mais avec balles
à ramon l'équipe et hop tu es un petit
peu plus organisé je pense qu'en plus de
moyens et c'est un choix difficile ça
pas été un choix facile je suis
convaincu mais marc antoine or il faut
mettre les gants à côté exactement
jamais plus montréal que le titre d'un
tony luc ses process légaux qui ont mis
de côté assez aussi leur prend leurs
propres première promesse balles à ramon
metz voulait faire de montréal une ville
bilingue voulait aller contre le statut
de la ville d'abord française c'est une
avant de langue française de montréal et
marc-antoine desjardins voulait en faire
une perle de la francophonie elle était
très très très loin
ils sont à l'opposé ans qui seront moins
un point ce qui les rassemble bon c'est
les points habituels en vue d'un
meilleur service à la population va
avoir moins de bureaucratie est d'abord
etc mais ça c'est ce que tout le monde
d'ici et aussi moi je pense que ces deux
gars là sont pas prêt ni l'un ni l'autre
avec mr je les aime beaucoup marc
antoine desjardins en particulier cet
immense bonhomme sympathique mais quand
valérie plante a été candidate à la
mairie ça faisait quatre ans qu'à poser
des questions d'une demi heure à chaque
personne qui a rencontré pendant quatre
ans sur comment fait sa pub ça et ça et
ça ces gars là sont pas passés par cette
moulinette là ils ne sont propres il ya
plusieurs de leurs déclarations qui
démontre que il y aura pas tout à fait
compris ce qu'elles étaient des pouvoirs
de la ville les budgets de la ville et
donc 2 go pauvres et qu'ils s'unissent
ça fait pas un gaufrier ça dont vous
dites pilotes vont faire attention parce
qu'il range fait envoyer du courrier pas
céder les gens tous qu'on parle pas
assez d'eux c'est classique là vous
dites que nos professeurs devront oui ce
serait d'excellentes personnes pour
devenir d'abord conseillé apprendre le
métier à prendre les lois et les
règlements les budgets et un jour se
présente à la mairie me les postes tout
à l'étape puisqu'il considère comme bien
des montréalais d'ailleurs qu'il ne
voterai ni pour plantes ni pour coderre
il se dit ça prend trois mois voit et ça
va être moi que mais je pense que c'est
un peu prématuré est-ce que ça une
distension plus à monsieur coderre où on
adam plan parce qu'ils ont plutôt à
gauche en fait sur certains points ben
moi je joue je me mets en désaccord un
peu avec avec l'iut parce que lorsqu'on
a été élu la première fois l'on n'avait
jamais fait de politique ni l'udc mois
de l'udc a été élue directement marc moi
j'ai commencé en bois déchets comme
conseillant n'y avait pas de guide pour
nous dire comment il fallait pas maire
de montréal mais les isérois du plateau
ce pas pareil westerwelle
mais dans ces cas là moi ce que ça
prouve cettex propos élire maire de
montréal mais ils vont aller d yvon
aller chercher les gens qui ne veulent
ni voté pour denis coderre ni voté pour
valérie prend t il donne une chance au
lieu de se diviser en deux deux
directives ni chez nous on peut être des
excellents contre conseiller dans
l'opposition comme projet montréal le
fait la première fois avec richard
bergeron accès présenter maire de
montréal qui a été élu dans l'opposition
qui a fait la première fois il était le
seul dans l'opposition représentant
projet montréal aujourd'hui projet
montréal est au pouvoir il faut
commencer quelque part et ils peuvent
avoir des ambitions mais si ces
ambitions là font élire une gêne une
quinzaine de conseillers tant mieux je
l'appelle ma question à qui ça lui le
plus madame plan toi monsieur coderre
krysna ben moi j'avais du mal un plant
parce que ce parti qui fait qu'il ya des
idées qui sont quand même plus
environnementalistes que l'équipe de
dennis mais si tu sais pas si c'est
parce que ceux qui veulent pas voter de
nuit ils vont pas nécessairement voter
valérie plantes ceux qui votent pas
valérie plantes n'iront pas
nécessairement chez l'équipe 2 de
nicolas le ca mélanger effectivement ces
deux électrodes bien distincts mais ce
que ce que code avoue l'avoir c'est le
vote d'opposition s'est tous les gens
qui ne sont pas satisfaits de madame
coderre et là une partie du vol madame
code à madame
oui oui oui
le climat
ça durait pas longtemps mais donc donc
les il ya déjà deux mois je veux pas
voter pour madame plantes mais je veux
pas voter pour monsieur cadavres ont
voté pour la troisième voie mais plus
déjà peu de gens qui vont voter pour eux
auraient voté pour madame plantes ils en
veulent pas a encore dit cherche un
nouveau et cherchent une voie dans
l'opposition mais acteurs tels que je
pourrais juste ajouter quelque chose au
niveau de la clientèle si on regarde les
gens la clientèle jeune va beaucoup
aller plus vers valérie plan mais ces
deux candidats ces deux candidats vont
chercher des candidats qui sont aussi
jeune dans cette voie là à voir là
quelque part rappelez-vous que l'âge
moyen à montréal
ckoi 38 ans et 38 ans selon les
statistiques 2016 2021 les dernières que
j'ai trouvé dans cette clientèle jeune
là avant peut-être que se retrouver dans
ces programmes c'est de venir à madame
plantes plus vous votre progressiste le
vote plus jeunes la diversité puis très
bon très bien est ce qu'on a le temps
d'écouter un petit extrait d'hier
débat sur la situation internationale de
montréal on va écouter monsieur coderre
et madame plantes qui répondent monsieur
colère dit moi je connais beaucoup de
monde sa planète
sais pas qui tu es sais qui tu connais
avec ma bonne amie anne hidalgo comme
ban ki-moon notre ami nous disait avec
monsieur hollande et les autres
notamment avec mike bloomberg lorsqu'on
écrit compact mais non moi je pensais
pas aller aux jeux piscine jours à peine
pour me donner de l'importance je ne me
vais les dépôts en francs sont des gens
qui je parle et encore moins que je le
dis devant les gens pour dire regardez
comment je suis b regardez comment jeter
important quand je disais l'axé tendu là
encore le finlandais se coderre il
plaide ai dit moi je connais beaucoup de
monde j'ai terminé fait quand achever la
politique
de bon des fois ça peut servir je me
rappelle que monsieur coderre s'était
beaucoup impliqué pour avoir une
une ligne ligne directe avec shanghai en
jouant avec les acteurs locaux en
poussant sur des acteurs locaux pour
qu'ils travaillent à voir cette ligne
moi je pense que c'est plutôt ça la
force et c'est de travailler avec les
gens d'ici pour avoir du rayonnement le
rayonnement par exemple de nos joueurs
de tennis ou des réalisateurs comme le
recteur de doudounes c'est ici que ça se
passe à dire que on travaille avec eux
pour que ça rayonne c'est pas en allant
se promener dans le monde sait pas quand
le maire va se promener dans le monde et
d'ailleurs comme ils le faisaient a dit
mme dizaine de reprises seul que ça va
changer les choses madame plante était
agacé une distension de vue hier par son
gilet que je la comprends c'est sûr que
du name dropping ça fait toujours c'est
impressionnant mais cependant lorsqu'on
a un réseau international ça l'aide à
faire certaines négociations pour
certains dossiers et on le vu l époque
où en 2013 montréal dans les journaux
internationaux étaient étaient bannies à
cause de la à cause du scandale de
toutes les tout ce qui s'est passé avec
monsieur tremblay en quatre ans on ne
réussit à ramener montréal sur la mappe
internationale donc c'est important
d'avoir ces contacts leur peau juste les
normes ouverture veulent cacher
nécessairement ya pas le cacher il ya
d'abord une question de personnalité
[ __ ] j'allais dire y voir des
flammèches ce n'est que le début entier
de la merci beaucoup à vous deux très
appréciée bonne fin de semaine merci